peu de d'annonces hein sur les avions de
chasse il y en aura pas dit le Dustin en
tout cas pas aujourd'hui même si les
Ukrainiens demandent toujours la
livraison de ces fameux avions le peuple
ukrainien inspiré le monde entier a dit
le secrétaire d'État américain
gauthierry vinsky la liste les armes
déjà promis en tout cas aux
Ukrainiens les lance-roquettes les armes
automatiques anti-aériennes les chars
bien sûr nous restons mobilisés a-t-il
dit en fait il veut s'assurer que ce que
les Américains ce que les Alliés ont
promis soient bien acheminés et bien
utiliser sur le terrain de guerre oui
parce que c'est vrai que l'acheminement
de ces matériels ça dépend évidemment de
leur volume mais c'est quelque chose qui
est quand même pas forcément très très
facile dans la mesure où il n'y a pas
36000 endroits pour entrer en Ukraine
tel qu'il est la situation aujourd'hui
et que la frontière avec la Pologne
reste le l'endroit privilégié ce qui
fera pas quand même dans lorsqu'on
déclaré les deux hommes c'est une sorte
de aller de d'auto-satisfaite c'est un
peu business as du jour oui voilà c'est
les Américains liste les armes et ils
disent que les Russes ont perdu la
guerre quoi voilà ils disent que les
Russes ont perdu la guerre qui sont
quand même dans qu'ils ont des capacités
et que le nombre peut faire la
différence mais que pour l'instant en
terme de morale et même en termes de
regroupement et même en termes de ce
qu'ils ont appris de leur
défaite ponctuelles ils ne sont pas
encore au point ce qui est quand même
frappant c'est que vous avez d'un côté
donc le l'aspect strictement militaire
des choses avec le secrétaire d'État à
la Défense américain et le général
Millet qui comme on le voyait sont bon
ils ont pas une mine enthousiaste mais
ils sont quand même assez content de et
de l'autre côté vous avez le secrétaire
général de l'OTAN yenstoltenberg le
Norvégien quoi
dans une demi-heure et qui dit attention
il y a quantité de choses qui sont qui
sont pas au point notamment l'affaire
des munitions les munitions qui sont
évidemment
dépensés par les Ukrainiens en grand
nombre et pour l'OTAN il y a une
difficulté à suivre le rythme ça veut
pas dire évidemment que les Ukrainiens
emploient les munitions de l'OTAN qu'il
prévoit pour son stock habituel non
c'est ce qui est dédié à l'Ukraine qui
va à épuisement beaucoup plus vite et
puis soldenberg il dit c'est offensive
russe elle ne devrait pas tarder parce
que les conditions de froid et dans les
logement font que c'est possible pour
les chats et donc lui tire la sonnette
d'alarme et les Américains ne disent pas
le contraire sur l'offensive non ils
disent pas le contraire il dit
simplement alors bien sûr qu'il y a des
secrets et dit simplement que la
implicitement que la situation n'est pas
aussi grave et c'est là qu'il y a
quelque chose qui est un peu une sorte
de tiraillement puisque stolkberg lui on
verra encore tout à l'heure bien sûr
mais attirer à plusieurs reprises à
sonner de d'alarme en disant au fond à
travers l'acceptation de un certain
nombre de
notamment les chars l'acceptation de
nouveaux budget mis à la disposition de
l'Ukraine les politiques et en fait
Austin et Miley sont aux ordres des
politiques puisque aussi il a dit
lui-même je ne peux rien rajouter à ce
que le président Baida a dit et bien les
politiques sont un peu là aussi sur leur
laurier en disant nous allons faire ce
qu'il faut et puis d'abord on verra une
fois que l'hiver sera passée il y a une
sorte de relâchement finalement et ce
que fait stalkbberg par rapport à ce
qu'on a entendu c'est de dire non il
faut pas se relâcher c'est pas
maintenant et d'ailleurs si les Russes
remportaient une forme de victoire même
minime ça redonnerait le moral ça
redonnerait de la langue non seulement à
la théorie russe de Poutine mais aussi
aux soldats pour continuer et aller plus
loin sur la non-annonce d'avion de
chasse est-ce que c'est étonnant de la
part des Américains est-ce qu'on sent de
plus en plus de pays est-ce qu'on sent
la réticence des pays sur
sur cette question de livraison de
nouvelles armes
alors deux choses d'abord le plus simple
si j'ose dire c'est que la formation des
pilotes Ukrainiens prendra du temps que
sera la situation dans un an même dans 6
mois on ne peut pas le savoir en
revanche ce qu'on peut savoir très
certainement c'est que si les Ukrainiens
ne sont pas soutenus de manière
continuelle y compris avant qu'il puisse
bénéficier des avions de chasse
américain ou autre là ils seront dans de
mauvaises dans un très mauvais pas et si
on les laisse si vous voulez se déliter
parce qu'ils attendent du matériel qui
viendra trop tard et bien ça sera
quelque chose d'assez catastrophique
pour eux ça veut donc dire qu'en
attendant
oui l'approvisionnement avec ses
appareils là il faut trouver et c'est ça
qui a évoqué loriostine il faut trouver
un certain nombre d'armements qui
permettent en quelque sorte de patienter
jusqu'à jusqu'au moment où les pilotes
Ukrainiens seront opérationnels sur ces
appareils
et alors ça c'est d'autant plus
important que rester opérationnel c'est
précisément en attendant que si jamais
les avions de chasse sont livrés que eux
soit décisif par rapport à la Russie
donc bien sûr que vous avez raison de
dire qu'il y a une certaine gêne parce
qu'au fond on ne veut pas promettre
quelque chose en espérant que peut-être
dans six mois un an ça ne serait plus
utile et si c'est utile ça voudrait dire
qu'il faudrait les employés en quelque
sorte dans une situation où la Russie
n'aurait plus envie de riposter parce
que sinon c'est une comédie gérance et
là ça peut aller beaucoup plus loin les
choses dans l'escalade rester avec nous
Gauthier on va